how's it going bro today reviewing a
very special subreddit we're reviewing
that Smosh the blu-ray HD torrent
download subreddit it's a subreddit that
I willingly haven't touched because I
know as soon as I I review this
subreddit everyone that goes on it's
gonna be like Oh pity pot review that
it's not funny anymore everyone knows
about it now haha yeah well I'm here to
ruin it for everyone you're welcome
don't care another reason I didn't want
to read this subreddit because this
subreddit just bombarded with ironic
memes and that's literally it and I
don't know if people like it I find it
funny like Peter Griffin holding gun
saying why did my reddit post not free
Hong Kong but why it's Hong Kong free
yet can someone answer this
oh is this is where they the black emoji
speedrun came from this is an historic
subreddit really for real though like
how did he do it so fast legit it's not
even sped up or anything dude I have so
much respect for speedrunners the grind
the dedication fastness of clicking on
buttons and repeating it over and over
that's dedication we did it reddit nice
420 billion hours of childhood
we did it subreddit that's nice that's
that's flicking hella nice dude I mean
the number of course of course would
never joke it is wholesome because it's
a wholesome number wholesome 100
starring the redditors ok let's say this
all right that's cool we got mustache
dr. Phil we have black dr. Phil I mean I
don't know who that is
that's you said sonic nice
yes send threats to people you don't
like you heard it here first folks now
go out there and get it
obviously it's never okay to do that but
you might want to consider my cat after
getting 17,000 karma on reddit chunker's
shortly before but bright 17k that's a
flicking lot dude on our chunker's to
the most esteemed subreddit of all time
I respect it I respect it not gonna lie
he just wouldn't stop eating all the
Lord I gave him that's fair that's fair
nice [ __ ] bro a little of the small side
but the shape is overall pretty
symmetrical and your balls have just
arrived right amount of hair the council
rates at seven out of ten first of all
respect for presenting it to the council
that takes balls in of its own I
wouldn't dare
I'm just here to ruin the subreddit
basically this is the last historical
piece of evidence that this ready that
ever existed
I named my dog five miles so I can tell
people I walked five miles every day I
ran over five miles borough Robert
Downey jr. you did not just say that
who deleted and why won't he let me see
his comment cringe Peter Griffin you
clearly don't understand how read it
works does your character have a slight
curve to his/her [ __ ] yes how does he
know that how does he know that this
freaking guy who knows everything it's
me hey you yes you simp no this is not a
meme i Obama am trapped in your phone
please let me free I miss my family I
don't freaking care Obama brah how did
he get in there yeah that's a good
question
guys I think I'm addicted to settings
and we've all been there
I wonder what I had definitely YouTube
but man if its settings I might have to
go into rehab enough [ __ ] rating time
for taste test I didn't know Gordon
Ramsay was part of the Council hello my
friend is anyone still watching it seems
to drop the soap please be more
irresponsible we
items as we're in jail and you can be
taken advantage of any moment
nice PP by the way see this is this is
another male Sigma societal problem
where we just assumed that guys are just
all gonna put our peepee in each other
we're not all gonna do that raise your
hand if you're not gonna do that I don't
have to do that you yeah that's what I
thought
cook Island speak right this miss
suffrage is blowing up because they meme
that it's still funny
a month later me go into work after
penis expansion surgery I like how they
call that expansion surgery yeah women
can get bigger peepee
why can't guy get bigger PPI something
to think about how small PP to get PP
extension everyone knows it's not the PP
that counts it's the inside of the PP
that counts it's Joey's new album going
to be provided on Spotify and soon just
curious let me know asap please Joey
Nichols no Spotify got trolled cringe
epic cringe your mama is a good rap name
to be fair this is Carl he is traveling
from all sub reddits call is not
traveling anymore as he was brutally
shot to death by police when crossing
the border of Israel this is one of
those stories that taken out of context
will look bad but called was embezzling
a ton of money into female hookers he
deserved to die I'm just gonna say it
I'm not usually before you watch
jacksepticeye's latest fan a video you
should know that the jump Thank You
respectable eyebrow man that could have
easily been PewDiePie
Jeremy is waiting for 5 seconds will be
like is that Alex flipping Jones that's
not a bad form bro look at that once you
start lifting that fats gonna all burn
off immediately this is the world if the
Foo Fighters didn't fight the food and
if the food fighters defeated the foo
what kind of would be real me going to
get my mom's iPad to watch the new
annoying orange video I'm glad there's
finally a reaction
for this I've always wanted to express
this perfectly why did it how did they
come up with this it's like borderline
the random cringe but it's hidden in so
much irony that it somehow works okay
you're rich name every number I'll be
credit card do it in the comments right
now prove it prove it now bruh Epson
ain't dead I use them to print and copy
documents family photos etc well I'll be
damned
I'm so late with these this is three
months ago that's funny
that's a good meme me at school with my
new okay buddy [ __ ] hoodie after this
pretty pie video and okay by the [ __ ]
they will swarm you mad push to anyone
that bought one if anything I'm making
this subreddit the rich okay your honor
524 people unchanged I want me to be
free you know out of all the things they
do to present in court it would not
surprise me if someone actually done
this come on Brock come on honor be like
bruh okay five hundred people what so I
can pose oh okay all right fair fair
that's fair I mean no you know there's
always that one [ __ ] guy that's as
soon as someone dies we're like alright
so it's not okay to do the three am
summoning @midnight video summit yeah
midnight yeah but this one it's gonna be
epic guys imagine if algebra was spelt
algebra I can't believe I laughed at
that that would be funny I think I agree
lion on bicycle you are so random LM L
finally obey neum so they are the ones
that discovered it the subreddit does
not get enough credit it needs more
upvotes who is Ted and why does he talk
so much why does he have so much to
please him say I had milder success in a
field so therefore I'm qualified to talk
in front of a huge crowd that has never
achieved anything everytime TED talk
ever basically you're welcome I had
success in this very niche minor field
therefore listen to me guys I can give
you experience in everything hey man
that's actually really funny I'll see if
I can work a laugh into my schedule do
that's a pretty savage ironic comment
right there my grandpa with Alzheimer's
when he forgot he died when I see a
Boomer calling small chunga's Bugs Bunny
I never thought of that that's actually
true
ducks in the shop why they gonna buy
idiot they don't have money cringe plus
they're Japanese ducks anyway I can tell
by raining the katakana on the D on the
deep fried chips I'm somewhat of a meme
weeb are you a minecraft fence because I
can't get over you use a carpet [ __ ] I
mean that's the first thing I saw cringe
you didn't know that no respect Robert
Downey jr. memes are now banned about
freakin time that dude was super cringe
am i right guys oh no this means
pewdiepie memes are gonna be bad this is
so sad and then he turns himself into a
pickle see it's this Jojo it's not
possible it's just not possible I'm
telling you I frickin saw it he turned
himself in here some of these are really
funny I'll give them that cure for
cancer Family Guy funniest moment twelve
I'll let you guys to decide in the
comments down below
both me and my brother watching our dad
received lethal injection we're all
gonna go through it at some point or
another so at least there's a medium or
we can sympathize sweet guys I just
realized something in a family guy okay
Joey says hi to someone but they are
weird not gonna lie Joe what's the
punchline please tell me there's a
punchline at this
ah when your wife's boyfriend lets you
stay up past 12 not gonna lie that dog
would you step on big Cheung Meyer for
18 billion dollars dude I wouldn't even
hesitate
I don't can't help you love there so I
would smash it in brains out eat the
brown part of this no way no way if you
guys do it first I will do it I will do
it a house divided against itself cannot
party Rock
thank you someone said it you ever
thought about how just how much history
censored there's no way we can trust
really everything but we know for a fact
the Barack Obama did say this we want to
talk to the CEO of racism is that always
the Chad guy is he real I thought it was
just a computer Jenner he's real epic
yeah oh wow that's so cool
there's a lake called Lake Chad it even
looks like Chad upside down it looks
like Chad are you serious when the water
hits it goes from virgin to mega Chad
that's society sexist when they realized
their parents Isis not by parents bruh
it was my dad and my dad's boyfriend
that did it okay now this is a big all
right what is it gonna be it's just pee
pee island it better be yeah it's pee
pee island I know the coordinates I
don't even need to see it it's mother
flippin pee pee yes that's epic well
done that's a respectable time to find
it too I don't think I can do it that
fast I honestly couldn't care less about
PewDiePie or any aspects of his life I
just care enough about posting on reddit
about it unpopular opinion I don't care
you like a pewdiepie go ruin another
server I know it
peopIe fans please flick off bro how do
you hit seven 420 so fast respect
respect it oh you like PewDiePie name
every subreddit you okay buddy [ __ ]
okay now I'm glad I did this that's
funny memes he's over go home berry pie
I had the mean now not funny only funny
with my small group
said okay bro you don't watch PewDiePie
that's kind of cringe bra have you seen
just replace that image with Giga Chan
cuz that's how we know it actually went
down come on stop pretending oh you're a
PewDiePie fan name every gamer moment he
had okay buddy that was a smash like
subscribe emerge I'm sorry okay I'm
sorry
I have done every reddit I have to get
to these eventually you know what not
sorry don't actually care at all as you
can tell because I did it because I
don't ah see you tomorrow actually no
see in two days bye bye hey don't party
bro
don't CSV subscribe thank you you know
what big peepees do they play
PewDiePie's pixel ings of course pixel
ins is a creature collecting game I'm
the primary shareholder over a bazillion
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time
35 pixel aims it's awesome deal with it
deal with it
[Music]
you